a remote Dirt Road in northeastern
Brazil the country's poorest region this
is where edaldo Santos takes us to see
where his cousin Luis Da Silva was born
or at least an exact replica of the home
of donalindu Luna's mother
the original fell down years ago
this was the typical House of
subsistence Farmers made of mud and
coconut tree sticks with no running
water or electricity
it's important to reconstruct this story
for future Generations so that they can
assimilate lua's story and realize that
they too can fight for Collective
Justice in these times of individualism
this was the bedroom with a family of
ten slept and this suitcase was used as
a closet until Lula's mother who was
illiterate decided to take all of her
children to Sao Paulo never dreaming who
one of her youngest sons would
eventually become
working at the age of 14 and went on to
become a formidable Trade union leader
and founder of the workers party or PT
he had little formal education but an
abundance of Charisma and negotiating
skills in 2003 Lula became Brazil's
first working-class president
he introduced sweeping social reforms to
combat poverty and lift the station of
working-class Brazilians from providing
education
to fresh water access for people like
Paolo Gomez
I began to love Lula long ago like a
father a hero because honestly he
Embraces the cause of the poor
massive housing projects also helped
lift 33 million people from poverty
during his two terms which coincided
with the Boom in prices for Brazilian
commodities
Brazil's economy soared
yet all was not well nagging charges of
corruption had long surrounded him and
his political party
a multi-billion dollar graph Scandal
exploded after he left office in 2010
just as the economy began regressing
millions of Brazilians turned on Lula
demanding he go to jail
if Lula is not in prison he will return
to power and keep stealing he's the ring
leader of them all
he was convicted and imprisoned on
charges of money laundering and
Corruption which he denied but was
released 18 months later when the
Supreme Court ruled that all of Lula's
convictions be annulled because of
suspect procedural practices
now 12 years after he left office with
more than 80 percent approval ratings in
older and perhaps more cautious Lula has
returned promising to bring back better
days especially for the poor the big
question is can he pull it off again
[Applause]
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Brazil